the pfizer vaccine is great news we all
know that but experts warn
we've still got a very long road ahead
dr anthony fauci says we must
we should continue measures like social
distancing during the rollout you all
have heard this before
he believes will likely be wearing masks
for most of 2021
now that timeline depends on how many of
us actually get the vaccine that's why
this is crucial
jonathan bigliotti joins us now from
santa monica in hard hit california
jonathan good morning to you what can
you tell us about the situation there
good morning to you gail the situation
is so dire here in california that
hospitals like st
john's here in santa monica have set up
tents like this in their parking lot to
deal with the possible
overflow of covet patients those
patients will be brought through this
tent
and then entering here through this area
where they will be treated and they will
recover this is all necessary because
in the central valley all icu beds are
gone just three percent of beds are left
here in southern california
as the death toll continues to rise
america's hospitals are under siege as
doses of the first coronavirus vaccine
arrive on the front lines in california
hospitalizations are up almost 250
percent
in the last month at usc medical center
in los angeles
capacity is falling fast this morning we
had no more icu events we were
completely full dr frank lavecchio works
in the er
at valley wise medical center in phoenix
he says his hospital is treating more
coronavirus patients
than at any other phase of the pandemic
the positives are
it's almost over the negatives are is
going to be a tough haul
for at least the next 90 days i think
we're going to be you know at capacity
over capacity there are now more than
110
000 people in the u.s hospitalized with
coronavirus
an increase of about 60 percent from a
month ago
dr anthony fauci warns that american
life may not return to normal
until late next year the vaccine right
now is not a substitute
for the normal standard public health
measures of wearing a mask
keeping your distance every day
thousands of americans are lost to the
virus
over the last week the u.s has averaged
more than 2 200 covet related deaths
per day people like 86 year old david
childress
childress was a retired firefighter and
a father of five
he died on december 6th his wife of 66
years
judy was by his hospital bed so many
families don't get to do that and even
the ones that are
they're so sick they're all alone and
i was blessed i was just so blessed
blessed just to be able to say goodbye
doctors are worried
about a surge on top of a surge as
millions of americans get ready to
travel for christmas
the two leading deaths right now in the
country are
our heart disease and of course the
coronavirus
tony and the skill the loss is hard to
express jonathan thank you very much